you know you know what they should do to
solve the NBA flopping situation if
you're cop flopping that's going to be
your basketball card
s
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys and
today we have Mr Walter Hawk back again
Mr Walter oh
ladies and gentlemen how come you're
wearing ramps the football's back
um okay you know honestly when I when I
put my clothes on this morning I was
like oh dude I always wear Rams when I
go They're Gonna think like I'm a crazy
Ram's friend that went to the Super Bowl
we already think that I did go to this
no but so like I was like ah but then I
didn't have anything else so
it was just kind of that day it was just
that day this is the only shirt you have
for today it's kind of like Steve right
he only like has like four outfits yeah
yeah I feel like I'm in that category
too really yeah I feel like you got like
how many fanny packs you got though I
got like two
I feel like he has like four civilian
clothes and like 16 Jiu Jitsu outfits no
I don't even have I'm actually running
out of juice you have like 45 rash
guards yeah but you know what's funny is
like I've never seen them wear them
they're all really too small and oh and
every time I raise my is that because
you're just getting swole getting fatter
maybe your outfit today's clue like a
like an air marshal that's what I'm
going for or like uh or like a producer
American Sniper oh yeah there you go oh
what a blind director
those lights over there
those are very those are hot in the bed
action this lighting is [__] action
and then the scenes over that way what
are you guys over here
[Laughter]
is it because I'm wearing Shades yeah
yeah
you got a blind guys cap
that's that's not like people say that
about me a lot they think like I look
like a blind and then blank
ETS
who says that just random people anytime
they comment or like they they clown on
me and they dunk on me so you gotta like
lie like you look like a blind Jujitsu
yeah or like a blind blank or something
no they're they're in the class they're
like why is this a boring guy teaching
us yeah it's because I don't know where
I'm going do you wear shades while you
do Jiu Jitsu no dude that's crazy I work
does anyone do that that's tight that's
crazy does anybody do that what if I
wear goggles like the ones that they
wear in like the old school NBA games
like they're straight up guns like
construction ones clean a larger one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that'd be
kind of fire but sometimes like you know
I don't think you need to see when
you're doing Jiu Jitsu dude it's all
feeling it's all closing your eyes and
you can't tell them are there any Jiu
Jitsu accessories that are kind of like
stupid to wear but people wear them okay
our buddy used to wear he's the only
person I've ever seen wear these
he's not American at all just matter of
fact he's 100 Guatemalan Heinrich his
name is Heinrich Nazi name yeah his
brother's name is Elwood and his other
other brother's name is Ludwig Adolf
Minecon shouldn't his name be einrich
einrich instead of Heinrich but it's
Heinrich nobody's Guatemalan so it's
pronounced oh it's pronounced why is it
Nazi Guatemalan I have no idea we ask
him this all the time and he's like I
don't even know my dad just
you gotta hear the theme in mind I guess
is it a theme I don't know it's a German
theme is it racist to think that his dad
wanted his son to be rich so he like he
enrich oh maybe no I don't think they're
a big pun family though so I don't know
I don't think so I like puns usually
though I think I think you're smarter
than all of us though because you saw
that in your head like before I didn't
even know I didn't even see I didn't
even spell I can't tell who he's looking
at so I feel like he's looking like he's
blind as long as you look in the general
area of a blind person I think you're
okay what's the accessory he wore these
socks on the mat because the mat was
really cold so he put these socks on
okay and they're like Jiu Jitsu socks
kind of like the socks you get when you
go to like Sky Zone oh it has grips
underneath yeah and we obviously were
like what the [__] are you wearing dude
are they toe socks though I don't know I
don't remember that'd be dope that you
know what that would throw people dude
it doesn't make sense at all you
shouldn't wear any socks on the mat
don't you think that would throw you off
though if like you're doing just with a
guy and then he has toe socks on and
he's wiggling his toes yeah and then
you're gonna be like I'm gonna punch
this guy in the face even though we
can't get motivated to win yeah yeah oh
that's true I can't get beat by the guy
with socks with grippy on the bottom he
wore him once I think once or twice and
then we kept making fun of him and then
he stopped wearing them wow I wrestled
the blind guy before that must be hard I
lost
wow hey Loki and my buddy competed
against one in a juicy tournament and he
lost one too the blindies they're good
yes
is that a Bard original it was a no it
was that uh
is that gabolino high school I wrestled
and I wrestled in high school and then
um you know sometimes like these [__]
high school sports they're kind of like
a rush you don't know what the [__]
going on everyone someone's making wait
someone's shaving his head because he
needs to like lose half a pound
somebody's got a blind stick coming in
well so like they say that the ref uh
he's like it's my turn so I'm supposed
to wrestle this guy the ref the ref is
also deaf so the way this guy speaks
dude I don't know where I don't know why
I think you joined the wrong division
the ref was deaf so you can't understand
what he's saying like he was like okay
it's like that like that right and then
I was like What He Blows the Whistle and
um this guy immediately goes for a
double and then when you have like the
cleanest double in the world you just
get picked up and you're on the ground
yeah and so my mind is half processing
what is going on half getting pinned
then the ref comes boom literally pins
me like 30 seconds but he didn't hear
that right oh the ref never mind keep
going well the wrestler maybe he didn't
see it
and then so I get up I'm still [__]
confused as to what's going on my coach
is like you lost and I was like I don't
really know what the [__] going on I
see
um that wrestler get walked to the side
and his coach is going to give him
Skittles he goes like this and then the
Skittles are dropping on floor and I was
like shut up I swear to God
I was like I was like what kind of
sitcom is it I swear to God I was like
that's [__] crazy and then I'm like I
go to the ref I'm like what happened so
their coach is blind too no
how did he miss did wait did your high
school wrestle like a blind school is
that what's going on and then the
[__] signing it on Braille day and
then I was like I was I was pissed so I
was like talking I was trying to I think
figure out what's going on with the ref
and the ref was like I said hear the
hands all about all his hands so what he
was saying is like because he's blind
the rules is after you shake hands
after you shake hands you have to stay
like you still have you have to stay
touching because you can't that's what I
was gonna ask you oh you can't just run
over to the corner and come back yeah
like this and just [__] don't make
noise
guys right here in whistles from across
different finally I'm like behind them
that's your [__]
then he's really good though because
that's what I was gonna ask you because
when I was in high school there was a
blind wrestler in Orange County yeah and
a friend of mine wrestling they said you
have to like brush his hands you have to
touch him at all times at all times but
the ref didn't explain that very well or
he didn't enunciate very well wow so I
couldn't [__] hear what the [__] you
were saying he blew the whistle
right it was good I blowing the whistle
because our [__] was loud and then and
then so the blind guy heard it [__]
picked my legs up and I was done and I
was like and then you know when you're
in high school that [__] happens to you
that's the joke for the rest of the year
lost to a blind guy and you know but
yeah kudos to the blind guy that's
Savage because you're not you're not
touching him and he's like I got this
yeah like this guy doesn't know yeah he
just hurt boom yeah shot in so the blind
guy you [__] beat Uncle Sam but
you'll never know what I look like yeah
you don't need to gesture or anything
he's obviously watching YouTube videos
all day
everybody's listening I don't know
these are you know these are crazy
stereotypes about blind people I don't
know anything about blind people really
it's that gabrielito high school it's
history there dude that guy knew exactly
what he was doing like he heard there he
heard the ref saying it
indistinguishably and he knew you didn't
understand and then he heard the whistle
and he goes I got this how come you
didn't hear the Skittles he heard him
bouncing off the top because because the
wrestler is blind not death the referee
is death
have you guys seen that wrestler with no
legs
yeah and he's like ripping oh [__] that
fool could do crazy flares dude do you
ever see him because he doesn't have
legs he does like the craziest flares
I've ever seen I don't know crazy is the
right word but yeah there's like nothing
against like you know wrestlers with
disabilities but
but like when you lose to one it is
different you're [__] our life up
yeah because there was a girl wrestler
too when I was in high school yeah
because that's a disability just being
totally well strength wise strengthwise
but then that girl won two matches like
in the whole season she won two and
those guys that lost I'm sure especially
back in like the like late 80s early 90s
where it was okay to say like you know
yeah all that stuff uh good word choice
it's very safe yeah do we do one of our
homies at a she's a Jitsu homie she
competed in an all boys tournament
because they didn't have any women that
showed up for the tournament and she won
the whole bracket the guy in the final
didn't shake her hand that's [__] up
that's messed up he was mad
he was like oh yeah maybe he was blind
did he catch the Skittles did he even
have hands dude he might even have had
hat yeah he had hands dude he had hands
oh I remember it so he caught the
Skittles is this what you're saying so
how many how many people did she have to
beat I think she only had like two or
three oh damn they were good these dudes
are like decent yeah I think it was like
um
I think a lot of it what it is too is
like they don't know how to enter the
match right it's like okay do I smash do
I destroy her because then like why did
you look to destroy her or do I just
kind of like
go easy and figure what would you do if
you were one of these oh my God that's
so scary dude and she had like huge tits
what what
you say to me what are you listening to
grab the bikinis let's open it up is
that what you wanted to hear you pervert
Yeah Yeah Yeah tell him dude I wouldn't
open up again I wouldn't do that I
wouldn't do that but would you go 100
like all out I think you'd have to bro
yeah I think I have to because my
teammate who is the lady who beat all
these guys in the tournament yeah yeah
she's really good and if like you
like uh think you're gonna beat her up
just because she's a lady
she'll kind of she'll snap your ankle
bro so did those guys afterwards they
have to give them pink belts yes
I'm stupid they just spit on them dude
at the podium like you don't deserve
this for a weekend
she probably hopes that they
underestimate her well because she's
very unassuming she's like she must be
yelled Hella Tight then huh she's hella
tight she's she's at your uh your place
her name is Justine what belt is oh you
know oh you know Justine I've seen oh
she's the one that well that Joe talks
about I've seen Justine whoop Joe's ass
all over the [__] man
she ain't gonna [__] around she's a
beast but it's like if you play
basketball it's that first time you play
against a girl that plays basketball
yeah and then you know because like when
you and she actually played yeah you
play your neighborhood girlfriends and
they're just like ah yeah I could beat
them and then when you finally play that
one girl that play actually plays and
you're like what the hell yeah because
most girls you see yeah you can't guard
her most girls you see when they shoot
if you see them shoot and they kick
their back leg up you're like I'm gonna
cross this chick up I'm gonna destroy
this chick yeah I'm gonna dunk on it but
when she could Square her shot up and
she shoots you're like oh [__] like
what's that form for jiu jitsu that's an
interesting question yeah is there any
giveaways that you're like like you
skipped to the mat
[Laughter]
there's some guys that Skip and they're
pretty gangster
something's out there I don't know most
sports these days it's uh you only
recognize it's boy or girl for the Split
Second the minute you engage it's just
body parts like if they're good you know
even like like yeah basketball whatever
you're like oh there's a chicken cool
and then the minute the game starts
she's Crossing you over it's just like
hips body parts
boy girl or like oh they're Asian or
white or black or whatever it's just
yeah it's just person and person now and
everything goes out the way that's a
good piece they're Mexican and the
laundry smells good dude that's actually
very true the water polo huh what do you
mean if they're laundry like if you're
wrestling or grappling with the Mexican
they smell really good you just smell
[__] good like very good very very
good I didn't know that sure if I'm
somebody offended or like that's inside
baseball for you guys okay who has a out
of out of your your data collection and
Analysis yeah uh who's just the the
generally speaking the most smelliest
the hairy white dudes really yeah hairy
white dudes because they kind of look
they're white Gees are a little yellow
sometimes is that because their skin is
so white no it's because they come in a
night class and they didn't shower the
whole day or they shower there's some
people who are gross bro there's some
people are gross thankfully we haven't
had that issue at the Academy but for
the most part there are some people that
are like like after you roll with them
they're stink kind of like
I feel like that's like an illegal like
uh what is it it's like an edge like if
you if you stink like crazy so look
there you know guys are you guys
familiar with Jon Jones
yeah Jon Jones he's like the greatest
yeah yeah top black dude one of the
greatest MMA fighters of all time he's
like to consider the goat he fought this
guy named Daniel Cormier and he said
every time they fought two or two times
he's like every time they fight Jon
Jones would come in smelling like [__]
you knew he didn't shower so like any
time he would grapple with him he was he
would be like oh dude he smells so bad
so that kind of does [__] with your head
mentally especially if you're not like
ready to do it that's an intentional
tactic I think some guys do that bro in
wrestling I don't know Barry if you're
in school our wrestling team we wouldn't
wash our our knee pads like all season
we wouldn't wash them and you know like
sweat it's just nasty yeah so then you
know there's that one move where you CR
you cradle and you put your knee in
their like face yeah so because a knee
pad smells like that guy would just be
like get weaker because he's just
smelling the nastiest yeah yeah that's
like that's a thing that's like a
biochemical Warfare totally at that
level winners want to win bro yeah
that's why I lose there was a rest he'd
wrestled uh I I don't know if it just
sounds racist but I am racist he's
Middle Eastern and he was hairy all over
you could smell him from like while
they're wrestling you could smell That's
How Strong I think it's the hair but
then when when the when the our teammate
came back we all moved from him like
we're like okay dude you gotta you gotta
move man like because he smell too I
think typically guys with a lot of body
hair they just tend to be a little more
stinky that's why on the flip side
Asian dudes which we have a lot of at
the Academy they smell like nothing
really they don't smell like a thing
there you know what of mine smells like
[__] though what my pillow
that's well how often do you replace
your pillow I don't know my head doesn't
have a good smell oh do you okay there's
two solutions one is where a beanie wear
a beanie when you sleep number two
you're supposed to change your pillow I
think once every six months six months
the whole pillow the whole pillow what
about the pillow sheet well the pillow
sheet you got to wash like once a week a
pillowcase yeah pillow could you wash it
once a week but like the pillow because
it builds up all your dead skin and it
it's basically soaks into the paper
every six months I'm like six to eight
months or something is that like a
dude's gonna throw up can we zoom in on
Colleen
do you switch your pillow out every six
months not my pillow most people don't
but you're supposed to like I don't
because I wash my sheets and my
pillowcases like every two weeks are you
sure that's not like propagated by
Simmons and sealies it could be it very
well could be yeah
this guy's got so many pillows on this
place it's my side hustle it's a good
Mark you have a promo code Walter
that is true I don't know what we're
going to title this video but let's go
back to sports because Bart is a an
Aficionado uh what is your favorite
sport outside of fighting stuff outside
of fighting stuff yeah look how
surprised he's like what I'm saying no
because I'm like because to me it's like
okay my favorite sport MMA for sure I
know that Dan right outside of right
outside of that just said that probably
boxing I get it right after that private
Jiu Jitsu and like uh Muay Thai yeah I
think that's why I said outside of
fighting specifically because I
understood that I think I think he
didn't specify what fighting is like
which sports keep going
I like those and then
um what about wrestling like Olympic
wrestling oh I like rice that's right
yeah and then Sumo and then slap boxing
and then arm wrestling and then
telephone booth boxes have you guys seen
cartridges
in terms of like thespians oh dude I
like pick a sport I like watching NBA
I could answer that for you they're some
of the best actors I've ever seen in my
entire life yeah flop game is good yeah
everyone like is that the new theme
though cause I haven't watched bass in
like three years and it's like like this
let's touch them just a little bit
I hate flopping but I do respect a guy
that could create a flop to actually get
the call the desired outcome yeah I do
think that's pretty cool tiny everyone's
just falling on the ground like when
they get hit and they're like oh yeah
people people
it's like key players at the right
moment so those are game changers yeah
yeah that's also like throwing pepper in
someone's eye at the key moment
also a strategy
but that's too big of a call though yeah
that's a flagrant too that's like
[__] like fighting and they're just
at the key moment you just squish their
eye real quick that's like when Draymond
stepped on sabonis yeah anything yeah
yeah that was flagrant too bro I think
what FIFA FIFA started the whole like
flopping like they're the worst players
they are the absolute worst at it and
that's why I don't like certain soccer
games because when I see one flop I
think they're worse than I barely like
soccer players yeah just in general
everyone's like what like 130 and then
they [__] and they touch each other and
they act like it hurts what's great it's
great I had no excuse me they get they
get carted off the field yeah as if
they're seriously injured yeah and then
like a minute later when the injury
timeout's done they come back they
literally run back they literally run
back and then you watch a game of rugby
yeah and then you're like I'm like this
they're getting hurt just remind it's so
reminiscent of when you want your
sibling to get in trouble you know when
your sibling hits you and you really
want that it just makes you feel that
same annoyance when you were a kid
you're like
and As Americans we all hate that I
think that's why we can't get on board
except I think we endorsed it the most I
think in the NBA Nobody Does that on
football NBA is the only sport where
they actively flash
actually no actually they made a rule in
the NFL about flopping so what they did
in the NFL they didn't call it flopping
though what they did if you like kind of
fake an injury so that the defense fakes
an injury to extend timeout to give them
the time to call plays they made a rule
that said if it's on the defense then um
it's you you get charged a timeout oh
[__] so because defense you know what
will happen is like someone's like oh
yeah they'll fall and then it'll be like
a timeout so to give the team a time a
chance to call a play
so they're like no no okay no more of
this so the competition Community said
we're gonna like penalize this by really
yeah so and then that Defender can't
play in the next next uh down he has to
sit out whether he's injured or not he's
got to sit down that's crazy how people
do these technicalities because I have a
friend that uh fights in MMA and one of
his most controversial fights the other
guy he pretty much uh knocked him out
right before the Bell so this guy's
Wally after 60 seconds he couldn't stand
up what the coaches did was like pretend
to put Vaseline but then drop it on the
ground dude that's a that's a that's a
thing so I've got to clean it up I gotta
clean it up so now they're like cleaning
it up and this one now it's more than 60
seconds this is um a bag of ice you
would spill ice on the floor and be like
oh [__] oh I gotta sorry I'm all thumbs
I gotta clean this up and you gotta like
scoop you know you know what they should
do to solve the NBA flopping situation
if you're cop flopping that's gonna be
your basketball card
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
hilarious
[Music]